Let's look at the solution
to our cache summary quiz.
We already know that the least
significant five bits are the offset
bits, that there are eight blocks
in this cache, and because it's two
way set associative, that means that
the next two bits are the index bits.
So all of these have
the same index bits,
which means they map to
the same cache set, so
we only really need to consider what
happens in the one set where they go.
This is a load.
It's going to be a mess,
because the cache is empty.
So we have a miss.
Now the valid, dirty, and
tag bits in the set are going to
be 1 here and 0 here.
Dirty is 0 and the tag is BCDE00.
It's actually going to
have slightly more bits,
but this is the only part that
will really differ between these.
The next axis is CDEF Is
going to be a miss.
And we'll fetch into
the other entry here.
The dirty bit is 0
because this is a load.
Next, we have a store hit
because we are accessing this.
It's a hit because it's a store.
This becomes dirty.
Next we have a store to another
word in the same block.
So this block becomes dirty.
And then we have a store again to BCDE,
so
it's just a hit that sets
this dirty bit again, to one.
So overall, we have two misses and
zero write backs in this sequence.